[Music]
so Peter you asked a really good
question about radiation perhaps being
the limiting factor in human exploration
and honestly this is something that
people are working on very hard right
now it is indeed a challenge the
astronauts on the space station are
actually fairly well protected from
radiation the earth has a liquid metal
core that generates a strong magnetic
field around the earth and amazingly the
space station which is about 200 miles
above us is still in that protective
magnetic field so when you're just
orbiting the Earth on the space station
the astronauts may get slightly higher
doses of radiation but they're actually
fairly well protected what happens if
you go beyond the Earth's magnetic field
though is that all of a sudden you're
vulnerable to the radiation of space and
specifically it's our wonderful friend
the Sun I mean none of us would be here
without the energy and the light of the
Sun but the Sun actually outputs a lot
of high-energy particles and these
create high radiation levels anywhere
where there isn't a protective magnetic
field so for example if you went to the
moon and in fact astronauts went to the
moon in the 1960s and 1970s
had there been a very powerful solar
storm when the astronauts were there it
may have made them very sick and might
have even killed them so in some sense
it was good luck that when the
astronauts were up on the moon not
protected by the Earth's magnetic field
the Sun was relatively quiet
however on a trip to Mars which might
take months up to six months you're not
going to be able to rely just on good
luck there will be solar activity there
will be bursts of high-energy particles
from the Sun so how do you protect
astronauts from that and we're working
on technology and in some cases it's a
special kind of sleeping bag that you
could get into and zip yourself up and
have some protection other ideas one of
the best protectors against radiation is
water so if you have the liquid water
tanks on one side of your spacecraft you
might be able to shelter from a solar
storm by putting the water tanks between
you and the Sun but if you're actually
going to be living and working in space
for a long time this really is a problem
if we were to send astronauts to Mars
for example they wouldn't be protected
from the radiation unless they could dig
under the ground and actually build
their habitats even just as much as ten
feet down would be an
but that's hard you know the Martian
soil is is very hard and rocky and not
easy to dig through and before you could
go there you'd have to send construction
equipment to actually build all of these
habitats so we understand that this is a
problem it's one of the things that is
limiting our exploration of the solar
system the robots that we build that go
to Mars like the Mars rover or the
spacecraft that there's one orbiting
Jupiter they have to be extremely
protected and shielded from the
radiation of space in fact our mission
to Jupiter right now is called Juno and
the instruments are inside a 700 pound
box of almost pure titanium to protect
it from the radiation of around Jupiter
even with that protection we only expect
the instruments to last about two years
the radiation is that intense so you
know you could not go to visit Jupiter
in a spacecraft and just happily sit
there and watch this beautiful planet
below you you'd be dead and probably
something like a day so this really is a
difficulty in sending astronauts out to
the surface of the Moon to Mars and if
we ever do go beyond so what are some of
the very very long-range ideas obviously
we're talking about about shielding
about how we could get maybe good
astronauts protected under the ground
but there's even stranger ideas that
probably won't come to fruition for
centuries even but they're still neat
ideas we are observing some
microorganisms that are very very good
at protecting themselves from radiation
and one of them is my personal favorite
animal I have like you know stuffed
animal versions of this it's a tiny tiny
little microscopic animal called a water
bear or a tardigrade and tardigrades are
just little microscopic animals with six
little arms and they live on moss
they've all they do is suck nutrients
off of moss that's all they do but a
single tardigrade could take radiation
levels that would kill a herd of a
hundred elephants this tiny little
animal is is almost completely resistant
to radiation and its DNA works in a
really cool way radiation breaks up DNA
that's one of the reasons you die when
there's a lot of radiation around and
somehow tardigrades DNA knows how to
heal itself right back up so we're
studying how tardigrade DNA works in the
hopes that maybe someday we could even
haier radiation damage to human DNA
there was a Star Trek episode I remember
where you know dr. McCoy gives people a
shot to protect them from radiation
could that someday happen well maybe and
we're gonna get there by starting to
look at these microorganisms that are
resistant to radiation figure out how
they do it and could we do that too
maybe
[Music]